joining me today on the Rubin report is
human rights activist and Bangladeshi
blogger a reef Rahman Arif welcome to
the show how I did it's really good to
be here
well I'm excited to talk to you we've
literally been going back and forth for
about five months we were introduced by
our friend Faisal Syed Ali Matar and we
were trying to work out getting you on
the show and then there's obviously been
some really horrific acts unfortunately
in Bangladesh over the last couple days
so we wanted to make this happen right
now I hate to start off we're still
we're starting off depressing but I
guess that's sort of the nature of what
you do right unfortunately it is yeah
I'm really glad that we are finally
talking and we should start saying
thanks to Faisal for making it happen
he's a really great guy he is a great
guy and he's doing great work and he's
spreading the message of secularism and
tolerance and atheism all the things
that you care about and write about and
the things that I talk about so all
right before we get into the events of
the last couple days let's just talk
about your history first because you
were sort of one of the first
Bangladeshi bloggers but give me a
little bit about your history growing up
to now you're in the UK and everything
else sure thanks for that I grew up in
Bangladesh it's actually a part of it
used to be part of Indian subcontinent
back in 1947 but in 1971 so 24/7 it was
part of Indian subcontinent then the
British split it between India and
Pakistan and Bangladesh was East
Pakistan still part of Pakistan and from
71 we split up because of a we had a war
and since then mahadesh is an
independent country I grew up in the 80s
in Bangladesh and nineties and in after
2003 I moved to UK so that's kind of my
history right so the history of
Bangladesh you know I had tarik Fatah on
the show
about two months ago and we went very
deep into the history of India and how
it relates to Pakistan and the partition
in 1947 but people don't even realize
that Bangladesh was also formed as a
country right at that time I think a lot
of people don't even realize they here
Bangladesh or they hear about
Bangladeshi bloggers I don't even think
that a certain amount of people realize
that Bangladesh is a sovereign country
Bangladesh is a sovereign country he has
been for the last forty five years
because it was part of Indian
subcontinent I think and Bangladesh
itself is not that great in kind of
communicating its history to the rest of
the world and there are other issues
surrounding I think we will get to that
at some point today but we are a
sovereign nation we are we are a small
geographic landmass but population wise
were really huge 160 370 million people
in that very short space it's it's
mind-blowing it's really really highly
populated right so when India was
partitioned and then three countries
appeared out of that the British left
and then it was split up what what is
the difference between the average
person that lives in Bangladesh verse
the average person that lives in India
versus the average person that lives in
Pakistan because at one time they were
all part of the same nation I think we
just fall into the trap of not knowing
much about Bangladesh so when British
left so Indian subcontinent was a colony
of the unit you know the British
monarchy for 200 years when the British
decided to leave
there was a deliberation on how they
should leave there was a request by the
Muslims to form their own kind of
country and India was Indian
subcontinent was divided between India
and Pakistan so at the beginning from
1947 it was only two country that is
India and Pakistan Pakistan was a
predominantly Muslim country India was
India actually formed as a secular state
not a Hindu country all the majority of
the people at that time
was Hindu background in the religion but
after 1947 the East and West Pakistan
was actually I don't know if you can
show the map which is quite interesting
India was in between Bangladesh was on
the east and Pakistan was on the west of
India there was almost 1200 miles of
Geographic gap between the two parts of
Pakistan which was unrealistic and it
was completely based it was erected
based on religion actually so Pakistan
Western East combined was formed based
solely on Islamic Brotherhood of calm
kind right and in 1971 we had a we had a
war but the question get to your
question
predominantly Pakistani and four people
are we're kind of Islamic Republic of
Pakistan India was a secular state
it was just a Republic of India I think
yeah the reason I ask you that is
because I know we could spend we could
spend the whole hour talking about the
history of this region of course but I
think it sets up a little bit of the
rest of the things that we're gonna talk
about so you grew up in Bangladesh what
was it like like what was the government
like what when did you sort of have your
awakening about free thinking and
atheism that kind of stuff I grew up in
the 80s and during that decade
Bangladesh was actually ruled by a
military dictator this this guy was you
know um we can't say directly but he's a
he's a CIA implant essentially during
that time because of the history of
Bangladesh itself at the very beginning
Bangladesh a day because Saudi a Soviet
Union was still quite powerful although
it was declining bondage was powered by
Indian you know support Bangladesh was
going towards like a you know a
socialist kind of state and the the
state the president was killed in a coup
along with his own family and then
Bangladesh
was fallen into the dictatorship so we
we suspect that if the whole thing was
orchestrated by CIA to kill the you know
leader and then implant dictators so
well when I grew up a mother she was
still having it's its social and
cultural identities so when I grow up I
feel I was kind of lucky because that
was the that was a very good time before
the decline started to happen and when I
say the decline since the 90s the
dictatorship fell and the so-called
Democratic parties came into power
coincided with the fall of Soviet Union
and those big Democratic parties
although democratic in their name but
they we saw a very worrying rise of
Islamism in in the country throughout
the whole of the 90s yeah let's pause
there for a second because I think
that's really fascinating what you're
saying is there was a military
dictatorship possibly had something to
do with the CIA and that was throughout
the 80s and then when that fell the
country sort of the idea was that the
country became more democratic
but then that ultimately led to the rise
of Islamism which is really where
Bangladesh is now I mean that's really
incredible because it seems like the
reverse of how things are supposed to be
it's actually a result of what the
dictators were doing a dictatorship was
gradually bringing in more and more
Islamic in a context into the culture
and into the into the core of our our
state they were introducing Islam as the
state religion in in the Constitution
because our original Constitution of the
1972 just before we serve just after we
got our liberation did not have anything
to do with Islam it in fact prevented
any party any political activism
activities based on religion and once
the the founding father of the country
bomb under Sheikh Mujibur Rahman was
killed along with his family these
dictators have actually clarified the
path for the Islamists to
to the country who was originally driven
out by the liberation war heroes and
they started to gradually become to take
hold of other state institutions and
when the actual democratization happened
in 1991 all the country all the state
machinery has so far already become very
kind of into Islamization in the and the
trajectory Wars towards Islamization
right and that sort of leads us to where
we are now can you give me an example of
like what what was the type of thing
that happened like I understand the idea
of you know Islamism was taking over but
what types of freedoms were actually
taken away that you or your family
enjoyed in the 80s that as this was
happening was it just things that you
couldn't say was it did television
channels change the news change like
what what were some like specific
examples the actual friction started
when I mean it we were seeing signs of
problems for example within the society
we just to step back a little bit
just to give you a context Bangladesh
has a huge population I told you earlier
one of the things that Bangladeshis do
as a as a kind of a nation is they leave
the country whenever they get a chance
this has been a thing for the last 45
years and it's mostly there are two
strands of people actually one strand of
people who are kind of freely thinking
and who wants to live a better life and
in Bangladesh it's not possible because
of the religious kind of atmosphere was
getting toxic and they were feeling
suffocated the other start was the
labors for example the whole of the
Middle East a whole of the United Arab
Emirates in Saudi Arabia the the
imported labor is actually mostly
majorities from India and Pakistan but
Bangladeshis are the major portion and
those the reason I say all these all
these things is because the environment
within bangladesh wasn't good for for
you know meritorious people are good
people to
Maine and actually helped the country to
do to become a better better country so
when when this happened people were
living obviously but the actual friction
started when we saw that our our history
of the liberation war itself was a war
with Pakistan
it's a nine-month long bloody war that
Pakistan actually West Pakistan at that
time started they flew in ninety
thousand armed forces and started
slaughtering Bangladeshi people in march
26th in one night they suddenly started
killing us and then we had to kind of
declare our independence the following
day and then we had to go to war for
nine months with Pakistan and eventually
with help from India we won the history
whole history is has got Islamism
ingrained with it because Pakistanis did
not like us although we were part of
Pakistan before the war there was a lot
of extortion of Bangladeshi people and
also the earnings that saw in East Bank
Pakistan or Bangladesh was doing the
money was going to Pakistan that means
there was a huge economic imbalance and
a lot of grievances yeah the most
grievance from the Pakistanis was that
we were not Muslim enough because we
liked our culture because we liked our
music or in a cultural activism or our
other cultural activity that that's why
Bengalis are more towards kind of a
human rounded human rather than the
extremists Pakistan is that you see
today yeah you know I'm so fascinated by
this stuff because as I discussed with
Tarek you know he described the
partition of India and everything that's
happened subsequently as just a wound
that hasn't healed so it sounds very
familiar it sounds very similar to what
you're saying that because of these
things that happened in 1947 1971 then
into the 80s and the transition into the
90s that people are still trying to heal
all this stuff that that's just not
being healed but I know we can keep
going on the history for
but let's let's move to the current day
because people do hear a little bit
about what's been going on with the
Bangladeshi bloggers but in the last
couple days some really horrific stuff
has happened including this LGBT writer
that was hacked to death so can you just
break down just what's happened in the
last few days so if I just give you a
bit of a context in Bangladesh illegally
being gay is not permissible so if you
if you have if you're found engaged in
any kind of homosexual activity you
would be the police will take it upon
themselves to arrest you and then
prosecute you because being a gay and
animal sexual activity is illegal in
Bangladesh however there is there are
lots of gays in Bangladesh because in
any any demography and also being a very
highly populated country there are lots
of queer people who definitely for
security reasons has to stay in the
closet however it's very suffocating for
them and because of a lot of activism
happening inside Bangladesh the queer
and gay reggae rights movement was
gradually trying to make their voices
heard and there may you know they're
trying to create a space this gentleman
jewel has man and he was a young young
guy gay himself he was a u.s. aid staff
and he was commanded by the American
ambassador because he also worked in the
American Embassy and he was he he
brought out the first issue of gay
magazine called Ruben so that means
there was really nice work being done by
these guys and although they are afraid
but they're trying to kind of show the
rest of the population that we are as
normal human being as everyone else and
we have the right as human beings to
live a normal life like anyone else
despite what religious rights wanted to
say yeah literally putting his life
on the line to get his freedom expressed
yeah absolutely
so in in a few weeks earlier 14th of
April for Bangladesh for Malaysia
culture is really important because on
that day we have a we it's a Bengal in
new year it's not the year for example
you Arabic you know you have Arabic year
you have Chinese year you have the
Gregorian calendar that is the kind of
the world norm but Bengal is before all
this happened for hundreds of years we
used to have our own calendar so 14th of
April is the first day of the new year
and we call it noble birth show on that
day throughout the country it's a
universal celebration that happens and
there's a huge rally happens in the
capital near the university and Bengali
gays have been bringing out processions
on the same day celebrating color and
life for the last few years this year
when they tried to bring out their
procession they were scattered scrambled
and then few of them are arrested this
guy actually went to the police and
tried to take them you know bailed him
out and he was successful however we saw
that things were not going well and two
days ago we heard the horrific news that
he himself and one of his friend was
literally slaughtered in his own
apartment by two or three unknown in
assassins who kind of walked in
slaughtered them walked out no masks
nothing literally like nobody to start
try to stop them today in the media we
can see CCTV footage of those peoples
clear faces but we know nothing will
happen about them yeah okay so this is
directly related to everything that
you've done because as I said at the top
you were one of the first people
blogging and one of the first people
talking about these things and correct
me if I'm wrong but I think you're on a
list
isn't there a list of like something
like 1200 bloggers that al-qaeda has
that that these people are supposed to
be killed you're on that list
right well I don't know the global list
about the 1200 people you mentioned I
heard about it but the blog that in
famous 84 blogger list that came out in
2013 that was actually the list that
everybody knows about the Bangladeshi
bloggers consists of only one of the she
bloggers and I met a very tough at the
moment this list is actually although
somehow Al Qaeda's name was added to it
but it was a joint venture between the
government and all the extremist
Islamists within the one Malaysia
country language government in 2013
announced actually sent out government
circulars inviting evidence against ATS
like me and and they set out they said
on this day we are gonna have a open
house anybody with evidence please come
and join the round table and we're gonna
discuss and see what we can do following
that meeting the list was leaked to the
media and since then that list has
become the list per se and we have
already lost a lot of friends from that
list right I mean we hear about the
bloggers be I mean I feel like every few
months you just randomly hear a story
unfortunately they don't really
percolate up to the mainstream but I'll
hear about it on on Twitter or something
like that so when did you realize that
you needed to start writing about this
stuff and how did you decide that you
were gonna put your own personal safety
I mean I I know you're in the UK now but
it's not fun hearing that you're on
these lists and every you know many of
my guests live with certain security
issues and things like that you know if
you remember I was talking about the
history of our liberation war that
happened and the problem with Islamism
because Pakistani military flown in
people in the country but they were
actually cut off from the rest of the
Pakistani mainland but they were able to
slaughter three million of our people in
nine months time because they had help
from local Dawa deshi Islamists and they
were using as Muslim Brotherhood
to help the Pakistani army and if we
fast forward today and for example last
ten years of my blogging history the
Islamist in Bangladesh right now they
are trying to erase that history of our
bravery we fought against the Pakistanis
and they were saying all the nasty
things against it and that's when we
started voicing our opinion about about
what they're trying to say but then we
tried to take it to next level and we
started criticizing what Islam itself
was doing to the country and that's when
the problem started because all the
Islamist propaganda machinery within the
country are kind of connected to the
rest of the world and they saw we are
saying things that not many countries
have said at that time I'm talking about
back in 2006-7 when we actually started
blogging and in Bengali because we have
a very rich cultural heritage very rich
literary base and based on those we said
Islam does not work for us so we started
you know finding issues with Islam back
in those days the things that you guys
for example know now we were talking
about that back in in bangla language in
our country in our blog blog sphere but
we were kind of assured that we if we
stay behind the anonymity of internet we
are not going to be physically harmed
although the Islamists themselves were
threatening us saying it's very well and
fine talking about these things in on
the web but if we come and meet us on
the street where I said you guys are not
civilized you can't have a discussion
civil discussion the second you heard
about Mohammed or anything problematic
about him you're gonna start shouting
and you know take out your knife and
you're gonna slaughter us so how can we
you invite us to you know discuss they
said we are not asking you to come to
discuss we come to show you or challenge
you that you don't have the guts to
actually say these things in front of us
I said yeah we are afraid of all yeah so
yeah so I actually interestingly I moved
here back into them three in the UK and
I actually
logging into the m6 so it's difficult
for a lot of people to comprehend that
if you're not in Bangladesh how can you
be a blog blogger and then how can you
be in problem the reason I say this it
all was made possible because of the
internet internet does not have any
Geographic boundary yeah and what I can
write in Bengali luckily I can write in
my own language I could write from here
I could write from anywhere in the world
and I could actually address or talk to
my colleagues and peers in Bangladesh
so that was happening and because I did
not was I was not worried about that
much about my safety at that time I had
a free mind that means I could say
things that was taking the discussion to
the next level and that was the one of
the key things that I contributed to the
discussion that I had exposure to the
rest of the world to humanity humanism
and secularism and I was kind of
absorbing those and then transferring
those in Bengali language and to the to
my current generation of my colleagues
so but when this all this listing thing
happened I received threats and I can
just show you quickly in 2013 when all
these lists happened this sort of
leaflets we're being spread outside more
I'll send you copy later on yeah these
lists were being circulated outside UK
mosques the funny thing is this list
don't sorry the list literally flies
don't talk about killing anybody all
they say there is these people has
blossomed and these are the things that
these guys have said however because
they were spreading those outside the
mosque inside the mosque the religious
leader was generally saying what should
be done to somebody who defames Mohammed
so you can imagine people coming out and
receiving those leaflets they were
making those connections in their head
one-to-one and what needs to be done and
that's how they create thread right so
wait I want to just make sure we don't
cross over that you're talking about
mosques in the UK now you're not talking
about Bangladesh so you're saying
they're so inside the Imams are
preaching about what you should
ooh - these non-believers and infidels
and atheists and all sorts of secular
people and then literally outside
they've got these guys that I assume are
connected to the Muslim Brotherhood's
absolutely yeah handing out these things
and now that now the names are on there
so they're not saying go kill them but
you just heard something on the inside
and here's the list of people yeah that
are doing this stuff and that's this is
in the United Kingdom yeah and the same
methodology is used throughout the world
by the Islamists and they're very smart
don't get me wrong these guys are really
smart they know how to work under the
radar but still achieve in creating fear
in people's mind and that's what they're
doing again in Bangladesh right now so
when you see that list and as a citizen
of the UK that's basically a death
threat to you even if it's not a hundred
percent directly there but it's a direct
it's a death threat to you and people
like you what do you do is there any
recourse you can take did you call the
authorities I mean what what can be done
well this is not virtual threat they're
directly literally threatened this is a
leaflet this is a circular from
ansarullah Bangla team so this is the
al-qaeda off short of Indian
subcontinent they call the aq is
al-qaeda in Indian subcontinent and they
literally have said if you are found to
be defaming the Prophet and few other
things about Sharia and everything rest
assured we will get to you at some point
so those are direct rights so I went to
the counterterrorism British police and
they it took them like two years to get
back to me but eventually in 2015 they
say it came to me and said yes we have
intelligence report about you so we're
gonna make sure that you are safe so if
you go somewhere let us know we'll try
to make sure that you are safe but I try
to do that but then again my my facebook
page the banner of my Facebook page is
not afraid because if I am afraid about
some criminals then I can't really live
my life if they hate me that's a
criminal act
they don't have an illegal jurisdiction
or anything to do it so I don't worry
too much I obviously try to save but
I don't stop doing what I'm doing yes so
some of this goes to something that I've
been thinking a lot about lately that
you know I've tried to go out of my way
on this show repeatedly to separate the
religious doctrine of Islam right the
ideas of a religion versus the people
because people believe in all sorts of
things some people believe in things
literally some people are nominal don't
think believe in anything really
whatever and everything in between from
radical jihadists to people that are
complete non-believers whatever atheist
Muslims that exist right but what you're
talking about really is Islamism which
is the political part of this because
this is this is political right if
someone's handing out a flyer saying
these are these people we they're we
don't want them expressing their freedom
of speech we don't want them expressing
these ideas that's really political is
that where we have to sort of go with
this conversation now because it's a
little bit easier to critique a
political idea than verses when we talk
about the religion and everyone starts
freaking out it is Lomb is not only a
religion it's a political religion from
the very beginning Muhammad his
campaigns were not religious only it was
political if you look at look throughout
his history he did not contain the
concept of God and what he asked us to
do to personal life or anything he says
Islam is a complete code of life that's
what they do it's not it's completely
different to for example Christianity
which already had a church stage
separation and also Christianity doesn't
I think historically never tried to kind
of go into the state running business
but I think recently I have seen some
evidence helping Ted Cruz saying that
you know you can't just leave your
religion you have to use the religion in
everything which is kind of the same
thing that political Islam has done so
far yes absolutely Islam is a political
religion so what what do you do about
that as someone that's in the
okay and you know you're writing about
these things and you're trying to
explain to people the difference between
religion and a political movement but
you're showing right now that these
things are really conflated how do you
get people to understand that the
political part is what we should be
afraid of and not what someone privately
believes in their own home as long as
they're not trying to push those beliefs
on someone that's the thing I mean as an
atheist that's what we try to say from
the very beginning however we have seen
a very weird baffling phenomena and I
can see that it's not only happening in
Bangladesh it's happening everywhere we
used to get that all the time from
certain political leftists and they used
to say you can't say anything against
Islam because it's Islamophobic and it's
it hurts all the Muslims and I said we
used to say that yes if criticizing the
religion itself some believer get hurt
it's their problem you know we can't
stop criticizing the problems because
political Islam encroaches its its
boundary and comes to our secular lives
and tries to impose its ideas on us the
left is never listen to it and they
always say you are victimizing Muslims
and I no matter how many times or how
many ways we say that we have nothing to
do with an individual Muslim who has its
own personal belief about Islam or even
he can believe that he has those
political you know willings as long as
that person doesn't act on becoming an
Islamist himself or kind of you know act
on a violent way we have no problem with
the person we have the problem with
their ideology but the thing is again
Islam the way it embeds itself in
somebody's mind that person becomes the
ambassador of Islamism it's within the
Institute instructions it's within the
training of a Muslim that if you are a
Muslim it's your religious duty to
actually what's the word for it it
should do t4 negate this idea not only
propagate but also too
support and and protect I was looking
for the word protect the religion from
defamation and blasphemy so if you see
anybody that's how they pass on the
agency to individuals everywhere and
that is really really toxic